ш але мені українці види мене міністерство
святі науки україни давид сибаса швидко
вчора вітаю всіх новим уроків торіс
христос минуло рік, що дозволяє на
глобальніше vse ese vid невиплаті був
хлібним міністерство святі науки
україни за досить коротку годину
вдалося реалізувати енеску важливих
завдань і силою його не стануть
фундаментом і змитий і у 2021 уроці ми
затребувані
державний стандарт базову середню святу
і відкрив і про свиню платформу для
дистанційного розміщеного на навчання
всеукраїнська школа онлайн встигнувши брати
з юнісеф за порожнім та сайт нома
помічених для батька вихопили
а також завершимо роботу на базовій
компонентом в дошкільне вас вид
фріформ іншого українська школа правила
сертифікації над 900 по дорозі чого
руку blu-bib ісанова моран допит
вібрацію світ міністерство вас вигляд і
науки України
фондом фридриха еберта наука про
методичним центром вище
дафа хавай попередню з вікою для
супроводу дуальної форми вас вигляд і
бруха ван ним того ще вступ на компанія
2020 року уроку проходила в умовах
карантинних ми ж ми перенесли її
терміни на місяць доступні kill 3 мани
чоловіки весь подавати оригінали
документів в закладі вище та метушні
електронну чи випадкову форму за
ініціативи президента для вступників з
тим годинного кубування їх територій
підлозі організовану роботу
195 останніх центрів донбасу України
то крима україна у сфері науки
інновації у хвала на 203
грантових води на суму на 38
мільйонів євро у мишах реалізації
програмних оризонт 2020
профінансовано наукових проектів на
суму на 250 мільйонів гривень за
піцу ком та конкурси проведеного
національним фондом
після джин україна позитивізмі девід був
з і в планах на новий рік ми перед
бачили газу клади за льону та середню
свиті субвенцію в апсиді 1 мільярда
гривень
на заходи ще з прямої на боротьбу з
рік струмінь респіраторних спотворює каву 19
у державному бюджеті на 2025 ширик
міністерство святі науки України
передачі але ви дотки фанат 140
мільярдів гривень ще на 20 честі 6
мільярдів гривень більше не в 2020 році
виродками в основному відсік вже ти нас
більше не заробітної плати педагогам як
поспішала і що зміниться на 20 років
сотки а поспіша грудня члена висимо і 4 500
він же наші завдання продовжимо цю роботу
на благо
майк будні у наших дітей кримінальних
будь-якого sweet там його середній
хода травня будуть ефективні ми
враховуємо зазначені результати у 2020 у
умовну сердечність усім вихопили в
4-му викладу ніж на у кого по 1000
супротивником за терпіння це
професіоналізм якийсь ви
рік відро коди налаштувань зайнявши важкі
бліда проти колосальні зус або знайшли
ху розвитку останні дикую всім
школярам то студентам за активний
ділянці початковому процес тягне рузи чу
ворогом їзду будки фоновому роті
ставте процедури максимальну ембід
немає
і круглий ти даний дозволяють не
щодо
Михайло рубінах по ну і мир і потишок
серця зігріва любов достатку нам усім
над ним не дані вичерпав енергією u2020
у цій потворності ці біси мені всередині нас
і успіх то радість
дорозі з витян та щасливого нового
уроку вам те світлова з 2 христова
спала до вас